this hopefully says to businesses number
one helps every time you get on to the
buttons and you're like ok these two cal
I do it you sort of reinforce that skill
so that when you get to the exam you
guys i've done this pizzas time I
remember how to get this cat food how to
change frequency etc ok but in addition
there's something interesting I want to
pull out from this particular set to
Ghana which would explore when we look
at the numbers so actually very helpful
is that we've got some all done by these
people let's look at the means for each
one of us ok we're going to use it here
this year do you notice the means are
connected just like these sets of scores
are connected i'll put them in order to
try makeover Mafia figure 2 set 1 250
what's the difference every tool yeah
and every single score if you just
tumbled down like this is plus two
together this one to that Victor so
therefore if you take all the schools
you add to the actual sale is taking the
mean and adding to the victims every
single one result yeah in the same way
downloaded 14.4 you see causes reports
of other quizzes and exactly double 7.2
and that's because on top yes the uniqlo
hello BB was Francis if you're ever
cease using quartile range though it's
kind of similar for trying to not i'm
jiggered interquartile range unique she
wanted history for that right now i
think it's easy when you have a nice to
see what chu chu is comedians what is
the median technical and it's just a
middle school right so that is cute too
okay she might she freed a little tricky
if you don't have a calculator that just
hand it to you it's easy to make a
mistake you what if you want the puzzle
it's five in a club that do you see why
it's five and a half what you do is you
say okay I don't think this guy and
specifically this for a moment and treat
each of these guys and the separate
group of school okay so five and six the
answer what kind of meeting and decide
which of course is by the huh so the
lower court arms between those guys when
you figure out that way what's the upper
quartiles and here go be nice it's in
between which is why nine hey crow flies
at half thank you now can someone tell
me I mean the mean change when I added
one to everything but the interquartile
range did not change why not your enemy
yeah ah so tiny it's not gas isn't it so
do you remember even though I put all
together the mean is a measure of
location it's like with the center of
this group at seven point two is the
tennis but these are not measures of
location they're not measure them with
centaur all central tendency what are
they mishit on the vertical the omission
of this is the basic originally bred to
how far apart are they spread out now
because you moved everyone up to it's
still spread out the same love deserve a
turn this is all fire and that's why
easily also this assay to see why the
devil deviations had changed these guys
are no further apart vanitas even though
and then of course you can see affecting
to the law school jumbled everything are
you done with everything so that does
spread out everyone do you see what's be
arranged for the first 15 of the brain
she are is 10 so everyone is spread out
much more that make it okay lock on just
down the bottom here how Hollywood
schools have to be in order relatable
outliers does anyone remember I let's
just do this one sir how do you get high
outliers how do we work better cp3 or
kids across yes i'll give the upper
quartile all you do with that plus 1.5
i'm being people challenge complete
wreck 50 * you're right successfully so
very good take the other quartile if you
don't need the quartile range is which
we do you apply that by 12 home and then
you add thanks to pop it going so it's
above that by a long way to work out
this one you do it your rest right so
instead of the upper quartile is will
get that one more time instead of adding
i'm going to try and tractor but it's
still what are the whole phone into
college
happy they'll be good